so I'm off to ultra I'm late if I miss
my flight I'm gonna be severely upset
Jenna's making we have to go breakfast
or something you go right at the stop by
Maddy by Baker I'll see your owner in
ultra I'll tell Kylie said hello
no he didn't if he loves Jenna Jenna's
like this is my new best friend now Oh
guys we made it I actually thought I was
gonna miss my plane
[Music]
[Applause]
and I'm back from ultra and it actually
filmed that much actually just went for
fun so our kind of wasn't really
vlogging a whole lot so hopefully you
guys enjoyed the video let me know if
you guys actually were in Miami for
altar I had a really good titles my
first time there had a lot of fun and
now this is the end of the video so see
you guys in the next vlog bye what is it
what is it what are you
so if you look at it that is definitely
not a raised camera the microphone is
also much closer to the camp